are you a pajamas all day woman in
lockdown you
i have to say to you that actually i've
been working at home since i was 27.
so i haven't really got dressed for
decades
unless you know unless i have to for
work
yeah so i have many all-in-one
non-persons yes and i have just been
looking at christmas pyjamas to wear in
the daytime
i mean my postman has never seen me
dressed
and you know the post doesn't come early
anymore
you know but i'm either wearing
something no i yes i am i'm either in
that i wear sort of like shorts and a
vest for exercise my
out my exercise in the morning yes and
then i think i can't bother to
i'll leave that on all day or i've just
got
some stained all-in-one garment
well that sounds lovely do you know what
it's the worst bedtime look i've ever
seen
my brothers you've met jamie i have i
didn't realize the other day for the
last 30 years he's been going to bed
in a t-shirt rather short and nothing
else
my my brother does that what's that it
is unacceptable man oh that is weird
is i think it's so your shoulders don't
get cold while you're reading
i have an awful feeling this well anyway
that's a nice example that's a nice
reason let's go with yours
that's my child but when they bring you
a cup of tea in the morning jimmy takes
it off
the hell is that i presume he takes it
off to sleep
no no it's like he's like in a little
minion he looks disturbed i think they
call it winnie the pooh
don't they yeah do they i think it's
called winnie-the-poohing
see they did have a very short he did a
little top and no bottoms
that's who they called it seriously
i think this makeup
[Music]
you